il donne le biberon aux agneaux
distribuer le fourrage aux moutons
d'autres travaillent dans des ateliers à
fabriquer de la céramique destinés à la
vente
[Musique]
d'autres encore lourdement handicapé
participent à des activités comme ici un
atelier son et lumière pour éveiller
leurs sens
[Musique]
nous sommes à trosly-breuil lieu de
naissance de l'arche qui compte
aujourd'hui dans le monde plus de 150
communauté de l'arche dans 37 pays dont
le canada qui en compte à lui seul près
de 30
leur mission faire partager une vie
communautaire et une vie de foi à des
personnes adultes ayant des déficiences
intellectuelles et tout cela au départ
ils le doivent à une seule personne
le canadien jean vanier 89 ans qui
habite toujours trosly-breuil dans les
années 60 jean vanille est un homme
révolté choqué par la façon dont on
entassait les personnes avec un handicap
intellectuel dans les asiles j'ai visité
quelques institutions et j'ai découvert
à mon terrible injustice un mot
providence il y avait peut-être trois ou
quatre cents à saint michel à québec
je la regarde par michalak âge et au
canada dont le québec partant il y avait
tous ces institutions ont enfermé des
gars super et s'était enfermé à vie
[Musique]
1964 jean vanier et dans la trentaine
quand il arrive à être libre oeil venu
rejoindre son guide spirituel le père
thomas philippe fils de l'ancien
gouverneur général du canada georges
vanier jean vanier a quitté la marine
royale a terminé un doctorant en
philosophie et a enseigné à l'université
toronto profondément catholique
il lui manque un sens à sa vie et c'est
être libre oeil qu'il le trouve
il lui vient cette idée tellement
audacieuse qu'elle apparaît irréfléchis
et irresponsables
je sentais que ce disque enfin décroché
face jean vanier achète une petite
maison abandonnée et en accord avec les
autorités iraniennes deux hommes avec
une déficience intellectuelle
on a commencé avec deux garçons ici
raphaël philippe
raphaël cac 40 ans et philippe qui était
dans sa salle aux pattes qui a
maintenant 26 ans ils vivent tous les
trois dans cette maison sans chauffage
ni électricité
un seul robinet à l'intérieur les
toilettes d'un jardin c'était des
conditions absolument minimale et puis
des gens sont venus m'aider puis il y
avait quelques de village qu'il a donné
au pp en relief parce que ce qu'ils
voulaient c'est d'être libéré de
l'institution alors il s'est tellement
heureux d'être libéré
et moi aussi les années 60 sont
favorables à la naissance de l'arche
l'église avec le concile vatican ii
s'ouvre au monde la société civile veut
en finir avec les asiles moyen âgeux
l'économie était en montée
l'idée de nouvelles communautés étaient
là les personnes avec des handicaps
c'était très vite après on a fermé
toutes les institutions en affaires des
mots providence en a fermé saint jean de
dieu on a fermé sa missa méchas la cage
et c'est parce qu'on a vu que c'était
pas bien
donc j'étais un peu précurseur de toutes
ces fermetures des institutions injuste
l'arche a fait des heureux
étienne bourdaire à 64 ans arrivé à
large
à 19 ans il si un jean vanier en haute
estime
ce qui mine ce qui me suit si besoin sur
un gars ici son lien profond de se
limiter ses singles
j'aime bien parce qu'ils hissent aux
religieuses il plonge large 54 ans
d'existence ça n'a pas toujours été
facile
ce type c'est un paradis parce que le
monde a toujours y découvre des conflits
des difficultés des banques mais c'est
ça il y a eu un scandale et un drame
le scandale une enquête a révélé que le
père thomas philippe mort en 93 avait
entretenu des liaisons avec une douzaine
de femmes aucune n'ayant de déficience
intellectuelle
drame maintenant un incendie en 2005 qui
a coûté la vie à deux personnes
handicapées 54 ans plus tard l'arche a
beaucoup changé
voyez seulement la maison originale de
jean vanier a grandi rénové sécuritaire
dominique la paix qui mènent une vie
paisible bagarre qu'il y aurait tout
voilà c'est ma télé et vendredi on
travaille
et voilà puis a pas que la fin de
l'appel à la paix ah oui non t'as pas
loin que de chemin parcouru pour jean
vanier qui aura 90 ans en septembre
je suis dans une période de descente par
exemple maintenant je donne plus de
conférence je crois que je peux dire que
j'accepte la fragilité qui est la mienne
alors la mort chez une progression dans
la fragilité et je suis fragile parce
que j'ai une communauté qui mène donc je
suis bien
si je suis fragile aussi j'ai aussi à
l'intérieur de moi une certitude que le
mystère de l'humanité de mystère odieux
qu'on lui l'humanité quelque part et je
crois dans cela jean vanier vit dans une
petite maison au centre de tri breuil
heureux toujours actif est prêt pour le
jour qu'on espère lointain où il ira à
la rencontre de son créateur
et toujours ce sentiment profond que je
suis aimé de dieu
donc ça ira pourquoi s'inquiéter
de toute façon on y va quand s'inquiète
quand sa kippa